Einstein came up with a number of
theories the first the special theory of
relativity he developed in 1905 and what
perhaps is best described as a hurricane
of intellectual fervor in the spring of
1905 where he was struggling to
understand aspects of space and time and
he realized that unlike what Newton said
Newton said that space is an absolute
eternal unchanging stage in which the
events of the universe take place and he
said that time is something that's also
universal it's something that ticks
forward second after second in a
completely uniform absolute way time for
you is the same for time for me is the
same for time on Jupiter the Andromeda
galaxy Einstein realized that that isn't
true
he realized that for instance as you
move time for you slows down relative to
somebody who is watching you that is not
moving with you time is relative he also
realized that space is relative if I'm
watching you speed by me he realized
that you looked shrunken in space
compared to how you would look if you
weren't moving motion affects time
motion effects space a completely new
understanding of these very basic
entities that since the time of Newton
we thought were absolute and unchanging
they're not their relative and they are
changing